somewhere out in the country  there's a man i'm bobby doing good  things  for good people getting his ass handed  to him in the process  any dream is possible that's what this  whole adventure is about  you see bobby's got himself a mantra  fight  grind repeat so whether he's in over his  head  oh my god whoa whoa whoa at the end of  his rope how you feeling there everybody  oh god or up a creek without a pedal  he's not just going to walk a mile in  their shoes he'll get him a brand  spanking new pair when he's done  this is your own hat no one deserves it  more than you you name it  he'll try it  even if it breaks him bobby bones  they're trying to break you  oh great breaking bobby bones  new series coming memorial day to  national geographic  any tips on what kind of pain medicine i  should take tonight